موضوع الابراج التوقعات من بيروت تنضم لنا
خبرات الابراج والفلك نور يسعد صباحك يا
نور ونبدا مع سريعا برج الحمل
[موسيقى]
كان عنده مشاكل
عاطفيه سابقه ان شاء الله راح تنحل هذه
السنه الجديده بس عم بشدهمته بالعمل
والعمل يكون كثير صائم بالنسبه له برج
الحمل
[موسيقى]
على السفر
السرطان حابب ينتقل من منزل يمكن اصفر
لمنزل اكبر احسن افضل
تمام الاسد
ايه افضل واحسن الاسد اموال يعني الاسد
عنده اموال كثير قويه عنده
فينا نقول انه نصف السنه راح يكون كلها
عنده اشكال وعنده اموال كثير العذراء
الميزان الميزان لازم يركز هالسنه صراحه
انه هو تركيزه ومال مال هذه الفتره هذه
السنه تركيزه ومال وينتبه لصحته برج
الميزان عنده شويه جو صحي ما راح يعجبه
برج الميزان هذه الفتره او هذه السنه او
نصف السنه تحديدا العقرب
العقرب العقرب بده يجي ابتدي يغير عن نفسه
لانه مدته هو ما غير عن نفسه ابدا بده
يغير عن نفسه
كثير عنده مفاجاه حلوه برج العقرب اوكي
ههه يسعد لي صباح الجميع الجدي عنده مصروف
كثير كبير بده ينقم مصروفه بده يعرف كيف
يطلع وكيف يركز على مسؤوقه عيد الازرق
صحيا انا بنصحه همم يدير باله على صحته
يركز على صحته كثير هذه الفتره برج الجدي
الي ما يصب اموال كثير بليز قد ما بيقدر
الجدي هذه الفتره يخبي مصرياته لانه زيته
ايام انتم ايام
طيب الدلو الدلو لازم يتعلم من اخلاقه
لانه عن جد هو غلط
بده يصلح حاله
يركز على حاله اموره
اوكي برج الحوت ههه
ههه عند الحوت همم بهيجه كثير تعب صحي
يعني عاطفيا بكل شيء تعب الحوت بس الحوت
عنده من هذه السنه سنه انتراجات كثير قويه
ارتباطات قويه يمكن عنده نقله نوعا ما
كثير قويه بالشغله بعملوا ممكن هو يصرف
بماده كثير او حتى مادي على عيني او على
اولادي هو مش مستقره بس راح يعوضها ان شاء
الله عنده تعويض كثير قوي والله زمان
نور بعرف انه الحمل
برج الحمل برج الحمل برج الحمل
راح يكون كثير
جزيلا
صح معنا وقت تفضل
نور طب اذا بنقدر نحكي اكثر الابراج حظا
هذا العام
الحوت الاسد في عنا همم كمان الدلو اكثر
حظ هذه السنه بتصور عنده اموال هذه السنه
كثير حلوه بده يستخدمه عيد الموقف في برج
الثور كمان كثير حلوه هذه السنه الابراج
بالمجمل الابراج
على الجميع